are you doing good it's just the two of
us
what's in front [ __ ] sure either take on
guys just want to say thanks to
everybody who's here today special guest
Brendan Schaub thanks for making time to
come down here to GoPro today also let's
say thanks to Boggs for setting this up
this is a hundred percent bosses
initiative initiative and reaching out
to Brandon and make it happen so thanks
the bonds and the people team for and
with that I'm going to turn it over to
Boggs to lay the framework for today and
we'll get to go discussion going cool
thank you guys so I asked Brendan to
join us really to speak to the nature of
Career Development right no two paths
are the same in Brendan's path is very
very to me and think his experiences can
speak to all of us and really not just
inspire us but kind of help reinsurer
and give us confidence in the workplace
and in our careers
first of all with our team like we have
a strong unit man no we might take some
criticism whether going like get rough
but nobody's gonna quit you know so even
you're only as strong as your weakest
link yet so my partner for those
don't know the show Bryan Callen is an
African comedian he's 50 years old and
you know he's been in the hangover he's
been an entourage he's been into all
these things one of the best comics in
the world he's been all over that TV
he's trying to be a TV guy he just did I
think right around or something like
that he's on the gold Birds he's the gym
coach on the gold birds on that but I
moved it when I first moved to LA I
didn't have anyone's number I only had
five number in my cell phone because I
met him on a TV show and I remember
driving down late so I took a risk
because I was on a losing streak in
Denver so I packed I sold everything
moong dal a Brian was the only number I
had in my phone I get emotional talked
about and he was my only friend and my
entire life I wanted to be like a
comedian actor is what we don't work
because I want everybody to understand
this this is this is a heavyweight
contender in the UFC this doesn't get
any tougher than this I'll try whatever
bring outside his reach this is this is
real [ __ ] no I mean the actin yeah
because my entire life I would be like
this actor comedian has no outlet I
don't know what to do and Brian gives me
that pass because he's a silly dude he's
been through so many ups and downs and
when we met at the perfect connection I
was getting punched in the face for a
living that's not good that that story
doesn't end well for anybody I don't
care who you are and I knew that and I
was I I wanna fight last fight won a
fight I fought the number three guy in
the world and I I lost that fight and
Brian was like we please focus on comedy
and shows and podcasts and tell me can
do it and I just needed that kind of
push because I was like I guess I'll
lose this next fight I can keep fighting
to be just a guy who made decent money
and then I just open a [ __ ] cardio
kickboxing school like this and I want
to do that time only
yeah like tae-bo like I'll just open up
oxygen in Brentwood and like teach
soccer moms like that sounds miserable
but Brian gave JP that gave me that
outlet so when I'm with Brian I get I
get that past cuz I have those labels
where I'm a fighter I'm this intense guy
and I'm not I couldn't be anything
further from that I'm not an aggressive
guy not a mean guy my biggest problem in
fighting was I never wanted to hurt
anyone which is a huge issue when you're
fighting so my chemistry with Brian and
he just gave me kind of that passed then
curve in he's like I said he's 15
Brighton so he ups and downs in the
entertainment and he has so much talent
but Brian will tell you this he had a
discipline problem as far as business
well family I come from my dad's very
business savvy self-made strict strict
do so of my brother so I have that
instilled in me being an athlete so
Brian and I linked it up together the
holes that he had I would fill the holes
that I had Brian would fill so together
it was this this weird chemistry where I
would hold blind accountable he hold me
accountable and we just played off each
other and yeah yeah or whatever weird
reason this 50 year old saved my life
and I saved his life because as a
somebody who listens to your podcast I
probably have a little bit more
information but chin yeah this is a chin
that spoke to me too so chin works on
the production side of your show and you
spoke about this and I kind of want you
to maybe tell a little bit of how chin
was able to secure himself a an
opportunity with the fighter of the kid
that's an important one for us to hear
reports oh so Jimmy's
in the back Eli producer our new
producer so the producer rates it's an
important role man turn events editing
all the show the sound the studio
he told me what gear he wanted to
basically build his perfect studio but
when we decided we Fox we had to make it
up and find a new producer
so we blasted out in the show hey we're
looking for a new producer we have
thousands of emails thousands of resumes
and I don't know I don't work on TV I
don't know get producer so people I'm
hoping would go through look at them and
they'd all look good and some we're
awful but still a lot of them we're good
and I was stressed out my don't know how
we're gonna pay some of it you need a
recruiter yeah so I was doing a set at
the Laugh Factory
there's a slowdown show and I get
offstage and I'm taking pictures with
people and this giant cream in these
period I've ever seen he walks up and
I'm like what's up hey I want a picture
anything no not on takes it and he takes
off his necklace and he has a necklace
and has a USB cord attached to it I
think Oh what's this and he was just
putting your laptop all minute next
producer I promise I'm your guy and it's
just that initiative and thank God you
have the skills
awesome
but uh your guys my guy are you but uh
yeah yeah he did that I just is the way
we're in a world where we got all these
resumes and they all look good is is his
way of sticking now just shows that he
really cared he really wanted it's one
of the best choices to be made for the
show he's a monster
who was it before Brian who was it that
gave you that ability to just
focus put things behind ya I just broke
grown-up in sports I guess my dad my dad
super disciplined really really driven
dude self-made millionaire hashtag rich
III don't know man I I think it's
something maybe might be born with it
just through experiences I don't know
what else to do I really don't I really
don't I just think things are gonna
happen and you can't control what you
can control and I'm give us swing I'm
gonna miss and we get it's gonna take
your ball and go home I don't know what
else to do man
I wish I could give you guys some sort
of advice or something like that but
what the hell else are you gonna do
we're gonna quit especially if you have
kids you [ __ ] kidding me I have a son
there's no way there's no way
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
one two three awesome
you're the best man I'll see you tonight
yes sir they said if you guys need any
more tickets let us know man cool thanks
sir coming then not many men can
withstand my punch
obviously obvious for sure gonna set it
gonna set it here on them black belts
and chickpeas chicken heads I think
you'd be surprised I think you'd be
surprised a bikini Fight Club
spike clubs spike Club hmm kids got a
piece on counter space on couple one to
cutie pies I still got it baby
lift your shield and now from the
honored studios in Playa Vista
California it is the moment you've been
waiting for the father and the kid is
coming at you live no no we're not live
that doesn't matter sounds better what
you see now it's the fire and fan of the
fighter the kid for a while actually
turn my brother into a dish when we
heard there was a live show there's no
way we were gonna miss it I've heard the
library kid since like
right after Brennan lost his last fight
started loosing the episode after that
and I was hooked because I just listened
he's logged when he does he's hella
passionate Brian's funniest bug I took
this funny as [ __ ] my eyes look because
I've been listening for like three years
now yeah it's shark eyes don't smile
what's up fellows hey buddy what's up
how are you what's up man we're men
we're magic tough tummy club going
through these we just gone through what
we're going to yeah we usually come up
with a bullet point of what we're trying
to think about we're not gonna let you
see this out because we try to keep it
as organic as possible we just have
these ideas where we're gonna go the
process very improv Brian almost to the
weather I was two hours late
he was almost 40 he'll I was almost as
hello so minutes is almost my first I
thought gonna have to do my hour special
yeah I'm not ready for at all yeah
things we thought were gonna ruin the
business bad we were scared I'm super
like crazy the plane was like that all
right you can cuddle my boy Brandon it
Brian
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] my pants right now this
is my girlfriend Melissa's I tracked
over to super pumped for the show gotta
show off the t-shirt the fighter the kid
we laughing all the way down to LA our
road trip it was good I'm supposed to
jump straight
that same all I can think about is
chicken fingers that are not here
[Applause]
love the [ __ ] hilarious first time
for me second set for him I saw quite in
the kid the first time they were here I
gotta say Santa yeah
I'm like I'm gonna hold him up too far I
want to see I wouldn't call him funny I
know he's been practicing at the Comedy
Store but I know he's pull through and
then in true fashion shop came through
with the heat and I laughed all the time
I thought I was at the comedies throws
at you know Laugh Factory it was I was
impressed and I loved it funny is a good
Kalla came through with the [ __ ] show
your deck and the houghton I like to
describe
okay live show veterans for live shows
three and sf1 in San Jose this is like
crazy thank you there's a dream and see
my heroes right you're my heroes right
here one day yeah thank you fighter the
kid keep inspiring people's doing your
thing
really
[Applause]
I notice a big transition yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a red light
[Music]
so we just dislike at started and so far
it's one of the best ever the most
amusing fans the most amazing friend and
I can't be more thankful than right now
and make me jump over jobbers recording
this
lots of it I was like this no shop was
hitting him and then he started hitting
with that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]